today's month is the first thing that we
are going to do is to check the news
announcements for this week there are a
couple of websites that are good to to
check the news announcements you can use
Forex Factory Forex life and I'm sure
there are many more uh in this case
we're in Forex Factory and you can
clearly see how today and tomorrow so
Monday and Tuesday there is nothing
really going on but from Wednesday
that's when the party starts
because on Wednesday you've got CPI data
that's the inflation report in the U.S
and you can see how they are expecting a
spike up from 3.2 percent to 3.6 percent
and this is concerning okay at least in
my opinion this is something that gets
me worried because if you check the
gasoline prices the the oil chart in
trading view you can check that too you
can see how in August because this takes
you back to the previous month so in
August there was really no months of an
increase I think it was like a two
percent or so but this month in
September we're already going up around
five percent and it's very likely that
now you know you might see a retrace in
the gasoline prices and then a spike up
so you can get to a 10 percent by the
end of the month and of course this is
something that I worse me because then
if that's the case and gasoline prices
keep going up now in September
the problem that we're going to have is
that in next month CPI
okay so basically in the next CPI report
you're going to see those gasoline
prices reflected in the report so you're
going to be expecting a higher CPI and
that's a problem because if you get now
three to six percent then it's very
likely that next month is around four
percent
and four percent something like a lot
you know the difference between three to
nine percent and four percent it just
sounds a lot more and that's how the
market reacts to it okay so I would
really like to see again I'm not
predicting what is going to happen on
Wednesday but personally I would really
like to see
something below 3.6 percent okay just
you know to make up for next for the
next API reporter I'm expecting a spike
High okay so that's my only CPI that's
obviously going to be something that is
going to move the market and for that
reason then it's likely that today and
tomorrow we might not see much
volatility because the investors and the
Traders are going to be waiting for
Wednesday's CPI report
on Thursday
we're gonna also have a lot of news it's
actually going to be a huge stay because
first of all you go the European Central
Bank interest rate Edition now the
markets have been divided here okay here
it tells you that they're gonna pause
but I'm also reading some economies
um you know their opinions are very
divided some of them think that I want
to post something they want to hike and
it seems quite like a 50 50. so of
course that's also something that is
going to move the market and you know
that you do trades against the dollar
I'm Bitcoin trades against a dollar so
this is also something to keep an eye on
on Thursday all right and of course you
got PPI PPI data all right so let me
tell you the difference between CPI and
PPI data the CPI is a consumer price
index whereas ppi is the producer price
index okay but if you notice they're
also expecting a spike up okay now in
the core PPI all right but in the PPI
month to month
and of course you also have good
employment claims so and the European
Central Bank press conference that you
know that's when you can see the if they
are whole key stories for the next
interest rotation so first is going to
be a huge state so
um
I mean if I have to guess what's going
to happen this week
then I will tell you okay it's likely
that on Monday and Tuesday you might see
less activity in the market but
Wednesday and Thursdays is going to be
Madness
these two days are going to be matte and
then on Wednesday do you know what you
got you got your friends from FTX Sam
the imma get an approval to liquidate
some assets let's see what happens okay
now I've been really happy about this
and to be honest it seems that uh well
everybody is talking about Solana
because that's kind of like their
biggest uh back so it would be the one
that you can see
more impact by this news but for what
I've been seen to be honest they have
been locked up for quite some years and
it's very hard that they sell everything
in once you know so I'm not that
concerned I don't think that Solana is
gonna go down until Wednesday most
likely
and then on Wednesday we'll see what
happens maybe nothing happens okay and
that's when you can see a shorter
squeeze so uh be very careful I would to
be honest stay away from Solana until
until Wednesday see what happens on
Wednesday all right
um the rest of the alcohol Market is
going down I mean I just checked the
chart we want to go through them but
I've I think one of the latest videos
was about this that the alcohol Market
was looking very weak
and it's likely heading towards making
new lows right so no surprise to see the
alcohol Market going down because yes
you have Solana going down today at
three percent but you also got polka dot
going down at three percent so
um it's in general the whole uh alcohol
Market the Bitcoin dominance going off
today all right so be very careful with
all coins at least for now um this week
I'm going to focus on on bitcoin all
right so let's go now to the charts
let's see what's going on there hang on
before we jump into the charts I wanted
to mention that I'm collaborating with
being X is one of the top exchanges and
one of the few ones that is not
requiring for kyc you've seen this year
something changes like by beat asking
for kyc and also be dead a couple of
weeks ago so right now being X is if you
look at the top exchanges the the top
one that doesn't require 4kyc all right
and we are also posting this campaign
with some rewards so if you register
with this referral link over here then
you're gonna get twenty dollar bonus and
if you deposit at least fifty dollars
and keep it there for at least three
days do you get another thirty dollar
bonus so if you combine that together if
you register and deposit fifty dollars
you get another fifty dollars for free
all right
and you also could even combine it with
this one that is trading over five
thousand dollars in trading volume okay
it sounds like a lot but it's not really
because because if you think about this
it's like if you know five trades with a
hundred dollars in times ten Leverage
okay you have a whole week to do that
and if you do so that's five thousand
dollars in trading volume and you get
one hundred dollars for free okay
so you can get 150 in a week basically
if you follow the three steps so it's
quite easy again this finishes on Friday
so if you are looking for an exchange
that doesn't require kyc that is liquid
um in my experience at least I haven't
seen
any problem or any scam weeks like you
can see in coin or some other exchanges
I'm not going to mention so this might
be an opportunity also because the
rewards that you have for this week okay
so that's pretty much everything that's
going to the charts this is my latest
Bitcoin chart okay uh what you see in
yellow those lines that's a potential
okay uh let me go through it okay so
first of all
do so this big drop from here so this
was some kind of range let's draw it
quickly I've been drawing this range
for ideas so you probably know what I'm
talking about already but you had this
range here
okay
um what we're saying is that this was a
deviation
okay then wait for price to get back
inside the range so in this Zone that's
when we open shorts okay and then
usually when you see a deviation in one
end of the range that's when you see a
breakout in the other end and basically
what we had here was some consolidation
below resistance quite various then you
see the drop okay
um there was two levels where price
could rebound from okay so these are the
levels
first of all you go there 28 300. and
you also got here
uh 2500 let me explain why okay this was
if you notice that was a previous range
so the logic said that if you fell off
from this range then you're gonna go to
the next range right so two places where
price could react from okay the first
one is let me remove this so we don't
get confused
there she go the first one was the range
size of this range okay but for about
what you would like to see is a
deviation okay and then you would open
along only if you can test the range
size
as a support okay otherwise and this is
you know in recorded in many videos
if you don't do navigation
you're going to continue dropping to the
to this range lows
right
um that's what happened moving to the
range lows this is what I I took all the
profits from this sorts right now I
don't have any swing trade open okay I
don't have any swing position I had a
swing sword it's closed all right now
let me remove this
we're gonna see what's going on now okay
now you can see the word is still inside
the range and we are holding the range
lows as support for now okay
when we had this drop I was telling you
there there is a lot of liquidations
here okay because if you check in
Hardware Capital you can see a lot of
liquidity in this zone now why did price
hit this Zone
but not here where there is a lot more
liquidity okay it's very close if you
notice it was like a you know three four
hundred five hundred dollars away
so the question is why didn't they hit
the song what did this means and I was
telling you that usually when you what
you see here
is some consolidation
okay
and a green candle big green candle this
was the ETF news of grayscale okay
so basically this drop what has done is
to scare all the retail Traders all the
investors okay and you know if you want
to continue going down and hit these
liquidations what you need is
investors and Traders throwing some
money into crypto so for that you know
do you release some news announcements
large big green candle everybody is
excited opening longs
trace this liquidity pull this in
balance
and then
they just reversed back down were
consolidating and because of this pump
the Liquidations in this Zone have
increased a lot so now if price decides
you know to come down
and hit this soon they're going to hit a
lot more liquidation so they could have
done previously
okay so that's the psychology of the
move and I think I I meant to read about
this I said the market makers a plan or
something like this okay
and so far that's the only thing that
I'm saying that I might be currently
happening now the question is
are you gonna drop straight away this
week
do that soon or
are we going to have you know one more
short squeeze
umbrella drop
so that's what I'm thinking okay either
one of those two estimators up don't say
Bitcoin you know pump in here and
recovering 30k again and continue going
higher you know there is a lot of
liquidations here and this consolidation
that you've seen this Zone in my opinion
is only to increase the Liquidations in
this Zone
all right so that's what I think about
in the midterm the direction is going to
be these liquidations and that's what
I've been defending for the last two to
three weeks all right so that's the plan
now if you notice here we have the
support this blue box you can see how
they are you know spiking price down
here
and then they bounce
okay so my question is are we gonna see
a new Spike here
okay and then a bounce because here if
you notice you have some liquidation
liquidity policy okay
you've got this one over here
and you also got
this one over there so all of this soon
it's a massive
liquid pool
that's an imbalance so it would make
sense to me
at least right now it would make more
sense
to First retrace these two imbalances
okay before dropping price lower but
again they might just dropped price from
here and that's why we have to keep an
eye on the news announcements because
that's why it's going to drive the
market okay if you got CPI on Wednesday
below
three to five percent well sorry three
to six percent below three to six
percent then exactly that you see you
know this this pump over here to attack
these two liquidation pools
okay and then you put that together on
Wednesday maybe nothing happens with the
Ft FDX assets okay maybe they don't get
the approval
two liquid assets or maybe they do and
just nothing happens because they plan
to sell slowly
okay so if those two things happen then
you're gonna see this boom here but of
course you know if CPI comes further
than expected it comes out three to
seven percent three to eight percent
three to nine percent then you know this
is not going to happen
and price is going to decide to go down
both for now
if we didn't have any news announcements
okay
this
is what I would be expecting
okay
so that's my view on bitcoin at the
moment but again I don't control the
news announcements so it's you can
understand that it's quite difficult and
it's very easily that I'm wrong with
this one okay because uh it depends on
what happens with many things okay
and see what happens with FTX on
Wednesday let's see what happens with
the CPI with PPI with the European
Central Bank interest rate efficient
many many things that I have no control
over but I can't decide how to trade
okay for example let me give you an idea
if you see here a pump
above the 4 or 50ma
and then do test your support you know
that's when you can open a long position
and you can start targeting this
liquidity impulse okay so that's one
trigger to go long
the same as if you drop below this blue
box and then here at this point it's
likely that you consolidate here okay or
even that you will have a little bounce
again to this Zone that's when you can
short okay
towards this liquidation Zone okay
usually you'll see more like this some
kind of consolidation below resistance
so
um these are my two triggers to be
honest now that doesn't mean that if we
get to uh 25 300 and I see a similar
counter steel behavior that we saw in
this one's here
all right then I'm gonna try along with
very small risk all right trying to
Target these songs but uh that's my view
at the moment with Bitcoin now I would
like to show you one more thing guys and
is the dollar chart so let me get you to
the dollar Index
here we go
now what can you see in the dollar
well
you can see that it's been basically
going up okay it's constantly going up
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom it's
going up now I have two things here
the first thing is that we got a gap
here in price if you notice
now these gaps
they tend to get filled so I wouldn't I
wouldn't be surprised to see the dollar
Index pump in between today and tomorrow
to fill this Gap here and that's when
Bitcoin could maybe Target 25 300 Okay
so so that's the that's the first thing
I don't know what I'm doing with the
chat hang on there you go that's the
first thing okay
um the other thing is that if you notice
this chart has been going up check this
out okay
31st of August
so basically
from the 31st of August or 1st of
September it's only been going up I
remember that Bitcoin trades against the
dollar so when the dollar goes up
Bitcoin should be going down now let's
go back to bitcoin and let's see what
Bitcoin has been doing since the 31st of
August
you can see the Bitcoin
has done nothing
sideways
and it's a bad thing or a good thing
well
Bitcoin should have dropped okay
Bitcoin should have dropped here not the
outfit of dropped by health and I don't
know how you guys interpret this botomy
it seems that Bitcoin
doesn't really want to go down now it's
holding when it should be going down so
that's what I'm telling you maybe now
what could happen is that the dollar
fills this Gap here
okay so maybe Bitcoin goes down you know
300 so 400 to 25 200 25 300 okay
and then
Bitcoin
Maybe
can't pull this move
okay because if you go to the dollar
Index you're gonna notice
how this chart
is looking into the Woodly it's looking
quite over extended I mean you've got
one two three four five six seven eight
green candles in a row so that's what I
mean the chart looks a bit over extended
okay it's true that you go here this
there are support but it's also true
that you go a week I'm the fifty percent
it's around here so why not could you
see the dollar in this retrace in a bit
yeah
um that little bit
it's maybe like a one percent and that
could give Bitcoin some room to go up
okay but again it all depends in the
Misunderstood is within half news
announcements
my analysis this week would clearly be
that we're gonna see something like this
okay
so um those are my thoughts on Bitcoin
now I would like to take you to high
blood Capital to see where the
liquidations are let's see if they can
if they can give us some kind of a clue
right
we're in hablo Capital so the first
thing that I always do is to look at the
delta
so the community of liquidation right
now are very low pretty much neutral to
sudo there was long liquidations but
then you can see how the drop price and
now it's neutral so there are not really
any race you can see that the total
solar liquidations are 446 whereas the
long liquidations are 490 so you know
pretty much the same nothing is really
going on board you can see in this chart
that there are a few spikes
specifically to the downside okay and
you got one here
uh 25 300 that's the level that I've
been mentioning
and you got another one at twenty five
thousand one hundred so why not could we
see
you know just stand up for one second
the charnos what it might happen this
week with the news announcements they
know what if it's gonna go up or down so
if we get a false move right at the
start of the week
and we hit these liquidations
maybe who knows
who could see a reversal if the news are
good right so uh Ayan is difficult
because I'm just trying to see this as a
normal QuickBook it's not a normal week
so
um it's kind of difficult to make a a
projection okay
now the Liquidations in the seven days
time frame you can see a lot of
liquidity at 25 300 again so of course
that's a level of interest that means
that
you know if I wanted to open a long
position right now I wouldn't open it at
25 600 I would wait and see what happens
at this level at 25 300 because it's
very likely seeing how close prices
towards that zone it's likely that we
hit this Zone first it could even happen
today all right and then to the website
you can see this Zone here around 26 700
26 800 that is a lot of liquidity up
there okay and you can see this
reflected in my projection of uh the
shortage of one more short squeeze then
in the one month time frame
you see I see a lot of liquidity uh 23
500 also uh 25 200 and you can still see
that well there's always some liquidity
above the previous highs right so that's
why you also you can see some
liquidations at 28 500. all right now
the problem with this is that really
these liquidations you can see that
yellow white is coming from here are
traders that have gone short
at this point
right so
it's likely that many of those positions
are already closed because hybrid
Capital doesn't remove positions they
only either increase them or keep them
the same because they don't know when
the retail Trader is closing position so
it's likely that with this drop here
many of these positions are already
closed
okay
um that's why I'm not paying much
attention to this level all right I'm
paying more attention to the 27k Zone
first that's why you don't see me you
don't hear me talking about it so
now in the three months time frame and
to me this is the magic chart the most
important chart that we've been saying
all right so you cut this drop
they don't hit these liquidations
okay they consolidate they Spike price
up with the ETF news and I want you to
pay some attention what happens to this
lower Zone okay you can see how it gets
brighter and now it's fully yellow that
means that the retail Trader opened many
Longs also in this during this pump
while doing this news announcements
so there is a lot more requisitions to
the downside now that they were in the
past
so that means that now if we see a drop
towards this Zone that'll be a very
effective move for the market maker to
release liquidity to the market all
right so that's what I think in the
midterm I have it clear I think that we
are gonna go towards the Zone 24 200 23
400 okay so yeah probably this lower
Zone because there is a lot of liquidity
there now also that's what I see in the
midterm happening
this could take you know it could be
this way it could take another two weeks
who knows and in the short term
I don't even want to go that extra way
depends on this week's news
announcements but again if we don't have
any news announcements then I will tell
you
likely that you see a push all level to
27k again first okay and then you see
that drop so that's for now
my view on bitcoin all right so thank
you so much for watching guys
and I'll see you soon